I am a big fan of your work it's always
I've spoken to you in the past it's a
it's always cool to talk with you thank
you I have a whole bunch of questions
and then before we jump into Sid at all
um you clearly know how to cook and I am
curious with what you post on Instagram
and people now know you know how to cook
um how many people are asking you to
like come over and cook for them
I do get certain people will do like you
know can we have do you think that was
it recently somebody said
would love to have Mr Tucci come over
and you know we'll fly him over and
whatever and he can just cook for well
he did I was like
why would I do that I just want to do
that do you know what I mean I don't
I don't just because I know how I don't
necessarily want I want to cook for the
people that
I know and love do you know what I mean
like like you yes or if it's a you know
if it's a charity thing or something
like that and you know of course but
um and I always want to go into
I always want to go into kitchens and
cook
with people because I want to learn you
know because I know how to cook certain
things but I'm not a chef hardly a chef
um I like to go and
sort of insinuate myself into a kitchen
and cook with somebody and have them
teach me yeah I enjoyed watching your
show uh on you know searching for anyway
um what is your actual favorite dish to
cook well there's a lot of them I really
love I really obviously I love pasta so
I love cooking any kind of pasta
um but I think like making a really
simple pasta like uh fresh tomato
with onions garlic
basil olive oil and then you just toss
that up with fresh pasta ideally or just
spaghetti or whatever that's to me like
one of the greatest dishes you can ever
have you don't need anything else and
then of course from there you can you
can just augment that and put pancetta
in it you could put you can put shrimp
in it you can put beans in it you can
put whatever you want and you wonder why
people ask you to cook for them I'm like
um how can I get him to cook yeah and
it's so much easier than you think a lot
of that stuff I cook the same things all
the time because they're comforting sure
um I'll move on to other things yeah uh
I am one last thing before Citadel I'm
really looking forward to the electric
State yeah another rooster brother
project uh what can you tease about who
you play and being a part of that well
obviously it's based on the graphic
novel
um so I I think that it doesn't I don't
know that it follows it exactly but for
the most part that that is the story
um
what can I say about it I don't really
know I don't really know what I can say
and what I I you know what I mean so I
want to be careful I'll just say that it
I'll move on so you don't get in trouble
but I'm really looking forward it's a
huge project yeah it's huge yeah it's
huge so with Citadel uh one of the
things about it so there's six episodes
yeah which of the six are you most
looking forward for people to see that's
hard to say because what I saw were was
a rough cut of six episodes so I haven't
seen really the final final version of
it I I almost I can't I like them all
and I'm not saying that because I'm a
part of it I like them all I think
they're amazing and it's so surprising
you know in one episode you think this
is gonna have the next thing that
happens that happens that it's so
complex that I'd say all of them well
one of the things about I've seen the
first three and uh it has more twists
and turns and I think anyone is
expecting yeah you know so I'm assuming
it continues with four five and six oh
yes right yeah how much did they tell
you when you signed on here's what we're
gonna do here are the twists and turns
and how much is it sort of like we're
making a big spy big spy show you want
to be part of it I read all the episodes
I was given all the episodes I read all
the episodes and but you have to
remember as we're filming things are
changing right so you have to keep sort
of saying so if that happens then what
about the thing that happened before and
how do we and then you have to sort of
Rectify that or you know change that or
actually know it works because this is
going to happen then blah blah blah blah
so there's all that so it's in constant
flux and you're just getting the
information and prepping yourself for
okay when we do this scene I know that
I've done this and but it's quite
complicated uh one of the things about
the show that I'm really excited about
is that there's going to be an Italian
version and one in India yeah and it's
you know a really huge Global thing
um can you sort of talk about that
aspect that like there's going to be uh
I think it's really cool yeah I think
it's really cool too all right as far as
I know this has never been done before
and I think it's I think it's amazing I
I think what it's going to do is
hopefully there'll be all this sort of
you know cross-pollination of actors and
directors and who knows you know story
lines and all that but I but I think
what it's going to do is
uh it's it's going to introduce people
to so many different actors so many
different directors uh that all all over
the world I think that's a really
wonderful thing I'm actually most
looking forward to the one from India
and I think that the success of rrr has
maybe opened the door a little bit
because India cinema and Bollywood has
been going for so long and I think it's
such a small audience in America yeah it
is it is and I think this is going to
sort of really open the doors and the
same with the Italian too it's great can
I ask you did you film any sort of
appearances or cameos and those other I
can't answer that question
sure I have to keep digging I don't know
I know I have to try I know you know
what I mean um one of the things of the
first episode it really has a movie
style action set piece on a tele on a
television series I mean that is a huge
action set piece yeah where you lit were
you excited that you were not part of it
or did you want to be a part of it
because filming that is a challenge yeah
I I mean those guys are you know
they're significantly Richard's you know
20 it's almost 30 years younger than I
am so uh it's a little easier for him to
do it than for me uh I I do like to do
the physical stuff but maybe not on that
scale we'll see but I thought it was
incredibly impressive oh a hundred
staggering no it's it is a movie set
piece I know I don't know how they do it
uh time and money yeah well there you go
yeah you know um so I really enjoy
Central Park and uh your voice as bitsy
uh how did you get involved in that and
how much fun did you have doing it oh my
God it was so much fun Josh gadd said
hey will you do this thing I'm doing
this is years ago now it's like four
years ago or more
he said um I'm gonna do this thing where
you play this you know like 80 year old
woman and I was like sure and then we
played around with the voice for a bit
and it happened you know the voice came
pretty quickly and then we just started
doing it and then it became really
successful they're not making any more
though I'm just sad about it there's a
lot of episodes out there yeah and but
but you're really great at that you know
with I hope you do some voicemails is
that character yeah oh God yeah I
absolutely loved it loved it on that
note I have to go I'm just going to say
uh good luck with the rest of your speed
dating thank you for talking yes thank
you so much